now coming out you're clubbing partying
Etc you're looking for that happiness
but true happiness and peace comes from
Islam just one minute I'm
done okay excuse us we're going to grab
okay that's he wants to talk I'm just
say you know
he's okay I should go my friend okay all
right if no you can go I'm not holding
him he wants to I I know we're trying to
go to a club yeah you can go look if you
want obviously not preaching Club yeah
I'm preaching something better than a
club I follow my friends with like can I
get a boo yeah no no keep the book is
yours did you guys know what the prophet
peace be upon him
said PE upon him said the one who gives
his will be a sh we here every Friday
and Sunday doing da to many people
alhamdulillah seven Shas two weeks
ago two Shas last week two Shas last
week you can support this and sisters
with the material Al hamdah some of them
we pay for some of them aldah we get for
free as you guys donated to the Salas
project alamah brother and sisters if
you can donate whatever you can it will
help our operations to have a cameraman
an editing team and some of the brothers
who come here and dedicate their time
and effort to giving da inshallah the
link is in the description box
below complex million times more complex
in the jumper so the question is who
created your eye who designed you the
way you look you have DNA DNA has
information information requires
intelligence
so that shows that there has to be a
higher power that gave rise to the whole
universe cuz the whole universe is more
complex than you and me so the universe
you get it so then we have to say there
has to be a ultimate power of source
that has created us and willed us and
fashioned us and shaped us do you get it
everything is balanced because otherwise
you can't say all of this came from
Randomness or chance it's not possible
can something come from
nothing and that's that's what I'm
Runing for like 10 years right there
I've studied like the evolution Theory
yeah and that's like one really big
issue with that of course you have like
yeah uh DNA RNA that's like really close
to each other but it's from no life to
life that's what I'm questioning exactly
so like shouldn't there be a God that's
like what course Evolution look you
being you believe in evolution doesn't
take God out of the picture really like
Charles Darwin he believed in God it's
yeah he did but it's a
Theory it's not like look look look look
the theory is not the issue we believe
the evolution of the
species different species that's fine
but I believe that God created Mankind
and then that's where we come from but
the point is even if you believe in The
evolutionary theory something it doesn't
take God out the picture cuz where did
the first cell come from the first cell
is a very complex thing so we say that
God Almighty there has to be a higher
power that wi it and that you have a
purpose you didn't just come into this
life to have fun party games there must
be a bigger purpose why you here where
you going what does God want from you
these are questions you need to ask
yourself you know that's why I gave you
the Quran read it and pray look look
pray and say God if you're there guide
me I did this 13 years ago I became a
Muslim 11 years
ago so yeah yeah yeah yeah 11 years ago
what what moved you to be so I always
believed in God I always believed
there's a higher power and I didn't
believe in any religion cuz I thought
religion is manmade to control the
masses but I had to logically say to
myself hold on a second if I believe God
exists then how could I not believe that
how can I believe that he gave me no
purpose how could How could a God I
believe in a God that has no purpose
everything here has a purpose that bin
has a purpose this camera has a purpose
your shoes have a purpose but I don't
have a purpose it was an insult to God
to me if God exists he has to have a
purpose of giving me a purpose that's
when I start looking at different
religions and different way of ways of
life so from there I started studying
Christianity Islam Judaism sism Hinduism
and the Quran was the only scripture
that has hasn't been changed hasn't been
changed by man it has miracles in it it
tells you to put the Quran to the test
it says bring something like it so
there's many many evidences towards it
but one thing that's special about Islam
is that God is one he's not a man if you
go to Christians they say God is Jesus
he's a man so how can I believe God is a
man like me and you who ate food and
went to the toilet do you think this is
a God to be
worshiped I don't really think good why
because you're using your rational
faculties God Is Bigger than us God is
No Beginning No End you get what I'm
trying to say we are I can't believe God
is like one of our cons thank you
exactly that's that's that's what's
called the fitra that's it's called the
F why because your the way God has
programmed you you know that without it
being all like different religions
coming and telling you different stuff
you know God cannot be a man I don't
need to tell you that you already know
that so that shows you that you already
have the inclination which is what
Muslims have which we call the fitra you
already know who Allah who God is and
that's to build a relationship with him
with the
Quran
yeah yeah let me know if you have any
questions for me any other questions
about Islam let me know I just I just
didn't study it enough to ask you like
take your time no SCH take your time I'm
here every Friday um Netherlands there's
mosques that you can go to yeah I I I
told you ear there i' like lot of Muslim
friends but like that's good it's it's
like hard to CH to choose what you say
it's like there has to be r reason yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah that's
why I'm daing you know no it's good look
into it read the Quran pray to God say
God if you are there guide
me and have you felt that in the past me
personally look look I'll be honest with
you I I have many things that's happened
that I could but I don't use that as an
Evidence because it's subjective a
Christian will come and say I pray to
Jesus and my life
changed we look at Islam we put the
Quran to the test because we don't
believe in Blind Faith we believe that
you should use your rational faculties
do you get it God Allah tells us use
your brain use your faculties do you get
it we don't have Blind Faith so that's
why there's L things that change my life
Islam changed my life I used to be here
I used to come clubing partying here
every every weekend every Saturday I
used to be come here partying like you
here at this very spot but you you when
you come you got partying girls clubbing
cars money nothing fulfills it you
always have emptiness you know why cuz
God has created that what does that say
sorry only in the remembrance of God do
hearts find peace this means God has
programmed you that you will only find
true happiness in his remembrance no
woman no money no car nothing's going to
fix
out yeah yeah yeah so so I would say
personally that if you truly find God
you will find contentment because now
coming out you're clubing partying Etc
you're looking for that happiness but
true happiness and peace comes from
Islam yeah Islam yes Subhan Allah it's
it's it's very interesting cuz your
friend's name is Muhammad
but always he's trying to take you away
but you want to listen like yeah his
father is like yeah yeah that
interesting yeah no that's fine but it
shows that you're interested man like
and and like I said before it will
change your life once you find
contentment and happiness and once you
connect yourself to God the biggest
achievement for me is to know why I'm
here and where I'm going because if you
don't if I don't know that if I put you
on a train and on this train you had
everything you wanted you're going to
say who put me on this train and where
am I going correct cuz you want to know
why am I on this train why do I look the
way I look why did I I didn't did you
choose your brothers and sisters did you
choose your mom and dad no so you didn't
choose these things so the point is we
are we are created without look do you
did you choose to have desires that you
can't control it's all a test Allah has
sent us here to test but the best of uh
the creation is those who have a
connection with God Almighty and once
you have that contentment bro if
everything in your life was taken you
would have peace and that's what Islam
gives you it gives you purpose it gives
you your direction when we pray five
times a day we remember God you get it
so so it's there to change your life and
once you do that bro you
won't what are you doing I'm just
listening to him
way just love I just love L yeah yeah no
it's okay I you're telling me it feels
my it feels a gap exactly exactly that's
what that's what I'm saying you feel
that Gap yeah and that's what happens is
you see when you have this Gap in your
heart you try to fulfill it with these
other things but believe me nothing is
going to fulfill it why when you have
bad food what happens you vomit your
stomach your brain tells you take it out
why because it's not good for you it
sees harmful things the same thing with
your soul anytime just one minute I'm
done okay
listen
and that's right just leave I'm I'm find
call
you you minute where where where' you
live I'll drop you home right no no
where'd you
live I live in Amsterdam am no no but
here you you staying here somewhere
today yeah yeah like uh just a hostel
that's fine I'll take you I'll drop you
I'm driving I can drop you yeah yeah
that's fine I'll drop you no I'll just I
I'll just go to them I mean if you okay
if they leave I can take you home I'll
drop you home no problem I'm driving
yeah let's go
excuse us we're going to grab okay
that's he wants to talk I'm just say you
know
he okay I should go my friend okay all
right if no you can go I'm not holding
he wants to I know I know he's just
strong okay no no you we trying to go to
a club yeah you can go look if you
you're obviously not preaching Club yeah
I'm preaching something better than a
club abolutely
yes I don't know somewhere somewhere
that way I don't know no off to you no
off no no no no look he wants to stay
I'm not I'm I'm not holding I know
you're not I know you're not I'm agenda
for tonight and their agenda is not our
agenda love you babe I'm I'm I'm like I
said I'm I'm I'm Al support whatever
you're doing yeah thank you no I'm not
I'm just everything everything
everything we do is against your
religion no it's fine but you still I me
just so fair like I respect everything
you do everything you pay for appreciate
you work for whatever I understand why
you're here to preach your message but
for us
that's fine I'm not going on
camera what what's your name what's your
name give one yes yes I think I think
you're I think can he keep the book no
you can take it look look again I'm not
I'm holding it he the one
that's I don't want to like that I'm
just like yeah I'll follow my friends
but like can I get boo yeah no no keep
the book the book is yours look look
keep the book uh take take my number I'm
curious can can I give you my number
yeah of course yeah just contact me how
long you here for curious I'm just
giving him my number he's he's going
just one yeah of course really want me
to go but I'm curious you
huh obviously
I'm
075 okay they say my name is I'm going
to write Ali da here yeah where did you
put the number like like over here uh
they don't want you to give it like
what's it what you doing Ali tonight
well I'm here you don't mind uh well I
do that yeah contact me we'll talk yeah
go with your yeah contact me we
speak yeah yeah but pray to God yeah
sorry I I he wanted to talk to
me go go seriously like I really love
song to you you said
really yeah but pray to God God
seriously to God I'll find you I I will
reach you contact me yeah I read it take
care contact me look after Ser no no
seriously but contact me I will meet you
all right take care look after yourself
yeah you're a good person you got a good
heart pray to God yeah God will guide
you feels better than what they doing I
mean I got to follow them yes yes I I
yeah I don't want to yeah I hope you
didn't go but I can't do nothing yeah
but after today contact me I feel I feel
the pressure no that's F that's fine
after today cont me let's talk yeah
let's talk yeah okay you're a good man
God is God is God is bought you here for
a reason than much all right take care
take care all right take care take take
care take care take care
bro uh that one oh brilliant